bonjour david alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre aujourd'hui pour le réseau
social à lyon olivier le verdict aura
lieu à 9h30 ce matin ici au tribunal
judiciaire de paris parmi les
associations de lutte contre les
discriminations qui assigne en justice à
twitter on y retrouve sos racisme sos
homophobie ou encore l union des
étudiants juifs de france que reproche
concrètement à twitter et bien c'est
c'est l'ingérence du réseau social sur
les contenus et le une expertise a était
a demandé afin de connaître quelles sont
elles les moyens humains et matériels
consacré par la société à la modération
dans le but d'engager par la suite un
autre procès sur le fond
en clair pour vous donner un exemple
précis et bien d'accord est un tweet à
caractère haineux et publiée et
signaliez bien souvent malgré elle ce
signalement ce signalement est bien le
tweet reste toujours en ligne est ce qui
montre une faille assez importante de
système est les avocats de ces
associations souhaitent comprendre
comment et pourquoi ce tweet n'est pas
immédiatement supprimées et pour cela et
bien ils s'appuient sur des études
réalisées par ds jussiê entre 2020 et
elle 2019 écouter dans la plus récente
étude sur les 68 signalé 50 sont
demeurés en ligne ce qui est certain
c'est que ça ne fonctionne pas et ses
dérives de modération vise les victimes
habituelles du racisme de
l'antisémitisme et de l'homophobie en
est en droit de considérer que les
choses doivent changer
alors david sur quoi s'appuient les les
avocats de ces associations sur le plan
judiciaire est ce qu'il ya un risque de
condamnation pour twitter finalement
bien pour le moment on peut pas trop
s'avancer olivier 1 sur une éventuelle
peine ou une amende
il faut attendre de savoir si une
expertise aura lieu ou non on aura la
réponse ce matin mais en tout cas ces
associations se base sur la loi de 2004
dite pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique qui impose aux plateformes de
rendre public les moyens qu'elle
consacre à la lutte contre ces activités
illicites 1 selon les termes exacts à
twitter pour le moment c'est a défendu
en s'opposant à cette ingérence estimant
respecter cette loi l'avocat en charge
de la faire dénoncent par ailleurs des
résultats totalement phocéen concernant
les études montré par ses diverses
associations
merci beaucoup david david kelly façon
directe devant le tribunal judiciaire de
paris